Quick--when I ask
what an alien looks like,
what's the first thing
that pops into your head?
Is it a deadly
endoparasatoid
with two sets
of sharp teeth?
Or perhaps a small,
green, bipedal creature
with large eyes?
Regardless of whatever
you just pictured,
you've seen these gray
alien extraterrestrials
somewhere before.
Called Zeta Reticulans,
Roswell Greys,
or simply Grays,
these extraterrestrials
are defined
by their humanoid forms,
exaggerated long limbs,
large black eyes,
small noses,
thin mouths,
and, of course,
gray skin or gray clothing.
There are mostly two types
of Grays--
the smaller drone
or lackey type
and the more powerful
and intelligent Tall Grays.
Grays are some
of pop culture's
most recognizable
representations
of extraterrestrial life.
But where did this depiction
of extraterrestrials come from,
and why are Grays the ones
mostly responsible
for all the abductions?
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
Let's keep in mind
that supernatural abductions
have long had a place
in folklore,
mythology, and culture.
From religious rites
to fairies,
deities to aliens,
history is filled with stories
of humans being kidnapped,
manipulated, and sometimes
returned to their homes.
That's partially
why it's hard to say
when the first so-called
alien encounter took place,
though one of the first
on record
emerged in 1638.
The journals
of Governor John Winthrop
of the Massachusetts Bay Colony
report the spottings
of various slight apparitions
in the area, some accompanied
by disembodied voices.
This rash of sightings
started a trend
that has continued
into the present day.
Most extraterrestrial
encounters
appear in
the English-speaking world.
The 19th century
is full of reports
originating
in the United States,
like on January 22, 1878,
when Texas farmer
John Martin
claimed he saw a flying disc
that appeared to be the size
of a saucer in the sky.
A local newspaper immortalized
the story the next day.
At the end
of the 19th century,
residents across California
reported incredibly
fast-moving mystery airships
about 45 to 60 meters
in size.
Beginning in Sacramento
in November, 1896,
hundreds of witnesses reported
lighted aircraft in the sky.
Many heard voices or singing
emanating from the objects.
One witness described it
as "cigar-shaped with wheels,
piloted by two men."
Similar sightings moved eastward
across 20 states
over the following six months.
One witness claimed
he narrowly avoided abduction
while out driving his buggy
some 80 kilometers
north of Stockton, California.
He discovered what he
determined was a crashed ship--
a metallic, smooth object
roughly 45 meters long.
Inside were three pale,
thin, seven-feet-tall
warbling creatures who tried
to force him aboard,
but he resisted and fled.
The shift
from fairy abduction motifs
and supernatural encounters
to more technology-based
extraterrestrial reports
could be attributed
to emerging technologies
and a cultural movement
away from superstition.
And let's not forget
that the 19th century
marked the first successful
non-balloon-powered
flight crafts in human history.
Gliders and controlled aircraft
powered by steam engines,
compressed air mechanisms,
and eventually
battery-powered crafts
were tested by governments,
scientists, and hobbyists.
Many of these attempts were
well-publicized. Just saying.
Still, all was relatively quiet
on the alien-encounter front
until the 1940s.
1946 to 1960 brought
another wave of sightings,
this time across
the Western world,
earning the period the moniker
"The Flying Saucer Era."
The United States, Germany,
Norway, France, Italy,
and Finland saw spikes
in unusual aerial phenomenon.
Most reports indicated
the appearance
of either a cigar- or circular-
shaped wingless aerial craft
accompanied by bright lights.
The press labeled
these first European sightings
a the "Ghost Rocket" scare
of 1946.
The public and intelligence
organizations alike
nervously wondered
if these flying objects
weren't alien craft
but real missiles originating
from the Soviet Union.
Cold War anxieties have long
been proposed by historians
as one explanation
for increases in sightings.
Other considerations?
The blossoming movie
and television industry's
embracing alien mythology
and the growing popularity
of the science-fiction genre
across all forms of media.
1947 was quite the year
for alien activity.
That year, U.S. pilot
Kenneth Arnold
observed nine objects
he said moved like a saucer
being thrown across water.
A newspaper reporter
misunderstood
and published
Arnold's description
as a "flying saucer."
As the news of the encounter
and term spread,
so many sightings
were reported
that the Air Force
opened an investigation.
And July 8 is an infamous day
in alien encounter history--
the Roswell Incident.
Following a press release
from the official
U.S. Army Air Force,
the Associated Press reported
to radio shows and newspapers
that the remains
of a flying disc
had been found outside
Roswell, New Mexico.
The U.S. military quickly
retracted its initial report
in a statement from
the Roswell Army Air Field,
claiming the object
was a weather balloon.
As unidentified aerial
phenomenon sightings increased
in the '40s and '50s,
so did the diversity
and frequency
of aliens
in science-fiction texts.
The 1950 movie
"The Flying Saucer"
capitalized on the fascination
with spacecraft.
Other movies like "The Day
the Earth Stood Still"
portray aliens as so humanoid
they appear to be humans.
Their technology and status
as extraterrestrials
is what marks them as alien.
Technology in the real world
was changing as well.
The first artificial
Earth satellite
launched on October 4, 1957.
That same year,
the Gray alien legacy
begins to appear in reports.
Brazilian farmer
Antonio Vilas-Boas
claimed he saw a red star
that grew brighter as
it approached him in the sky.
He testified that short beings
from outer space
wearing gray suits
took him to the spacecraft
and performed physical
and sexual experiments on him.
Gray abductions did become
a global sensation
four years later
in New Hampshire
on September 19, 1961.
As Barney and Betty Hill
were driving down
a lone stretch of dark road
on Highway 3
in the White Mountains,
Betty noticed strange lights
in the sky
that she initially mistook
for a falling star
until it moved upward
and increased in intensity.
The couple stopped the car
to look at the lights
and walk their dog.
While Barney was with the dog,
Betty looked at the lights
through binoculars,
and what she saw
shocked them both.
Betty would later describe
a saucer-shaped craft
with flashing
multi-colored lights
moving jerkily
through the sky.
The duo jumped in their car
again to pursue the phenomenon.
It suddenly came closer--
much closer--
hovering over them
in the middle of the highway.
Barney emerged,
gun and binoculars in hand.
The pancake-like craft
had a window,
and Barney could see at least
half a dozen figures inside.
They began to emerge.
Gray in color, human-like,
but smaller in stature
and with massive eyes,
the creatures were accompanied
by a buzzing sound.
Barney and Betty
entered a trance state.
When they returned
to consciousness,
seated in the car
two hours later,
56 kilometers away,
neither could remember
where they had been
or what had happened.
They concluded they
had been abducted by aliens.
Their experience
became the first
widely publicized
alien abduction.
The next morning,
a few unusual things
seemed to confirm
their suspicion.
Their watches were stopped;
a pink, powdery substance
stained Betty's dress;
the binocular straps
were broken;
and circular indents adorned
the trunk of their car.
Days later,
Betty would report vivid dreams
that filled in the details
of their lost time.
In the dreams, the couple
was taken aboard the craft,
physically examined in detail,
and questioned telepathically
by the extraterrestrials.
It wasn't
until three years later
that they took their story
public,
first to a UFO study group,
and then a month later,
to seek the help
of a hypnotherapist.
He concluded that their
experience was a result
of Betty sharing her dreams,
not an actual
alien abduction.
The Hills eventually
reported the incident
to the U.S. Air Force,
who basically ignored it.
The National Investigations
Committee on Aerial Phenomenon,
however,
found the story plausible.
Following Vilas-Boas'
and the Hills' reports,
human extraterrestrial
encounters took on
a rather specific formula--
a person is taken,
usually against their will,
onto an alien craft
where they experience
a traumatic
physical examination
which includes
the reproductive system
in what would
come to be known as "probing."
Sexual activity between humans
and non-humans may occur.
The person is then returned
with only a fragmented or
partial memory of the events.
These experiences seemed
ripped from pulp novels
and movie screens of the time
and gained
more and more notoriety
as they were told and retold
in both fiction and nonfiction.
Today, may scholars
have connected
the Hills' abduction story
and its popularity
to racial anxiety.
Betty and Barney
were an interracial couple
and active members
of the New Hampshire
Civil Rights Movement,
and by their own account,
the aliens were fascinated
by their differences
in skin color.
Apparently, so was
the American public.
John G. Fuller wrote a book
about the Hill abduction
in 1966.
"The Interrupted Journey" was
commercially successful enough
that it inspired a 1975
film adaptation,
"The UFO Incident."
That same year in Arizona,
Travis Walton reported
an abduction incident
almost exactly like the one
experienced by the Hills
just two weeks after
"The UFO Incident"
aired on television.
Hill would record
his experience
in the book,
"Fire in the Sky,"
which also became a film.
Accounts
of alien abductions spiked
in conjunction with an increase
in extraterrestrial encounters
onscreen,
continuing a cycle of fiction
imitating life
imitating fiction.
The appearance of Grays
was solidified and popularized
in 1977
with Steven Spielberg's
"Close Encounters
of the Third Kind"
and again in 1988
with the cover art
of Whitley Strieber's
true-life alien encounters
science-fiction book
"Communion."
Almost 40 years later,
in 1980,
"The Roswell Incident"
was published,
reigniting the belief
that the 1947 crash
was evidence of aliens on Earth
and a government cover-up.
And in 1989,
"Unsolved Mysteries"
aired a so-called
investigative report
into the rumored
extraterrestrial activity
in Roswell
to 28 million viewers.
The 1990s brought a veritable
golden age of alien abductions
in popular culture.
To better understand
the community
that has arisen
around this subject of aliens,
I asked for some help
from "Subcultured's"
Josef Lorenzo,
who recently took a deep dive
into the UFO
enthusiast community.
I've been using
the word "enthusiast"
to describe the community
because not everyone
is a believer.
Some people that are
in the community
are skeptics;
other people are believers.
And so I've been using
the word "enthusiast"
to kind of describe
the community as a whole
because they do come together--
they have this one
common goal,
and that goal is that
they want more information.
There's a big
pop-culture element
of people's interest
in UFOs
and UAPs, and I think
a lot of that
goes to "The X-Files."
Like, "The X-Files" obviously
was huge in the '90s.
Everyone was crushing
over Scully and Mulder,
and it was like
this huge resurgence.
So there has been this,
like, growing interest
in aliens
as an aesthetic.
But I do think that
there is this reality
that people are just also
interested in aliens
as, like, a real thing too,
not just an aesthetic.
It's kind of like
an underlying cause for that.
(Emily)
The Hill abduction inspired
an episode
of "The X-Files" and NBC's
"Dark Skies" series.
Carl Sagan even discussed it
on his "Cosmos" show.
Books, including academic ones,
abounded.
Reputable newspapers wrote
stories of reported abductions.
Tabloid front pages,
TV shows,
radio programs--everyone
wanted in on the trend.
Hollywood blockbusters
like "Independence Day,"
"Fire in the Sky,"
"Progeny," "Contact,"
"Mars Attacks," and
"Men in Black" to name a few
likewise profited
off our alien obsession.
Since the mid-20th century,
there have been
four million reports
of alien abductions
in the U.S. alone.
The biggest thing
that kind of happened
for the community was that,
in 2017, when that "New York
Times" report came out
admitting that the Pentagon
had a secret program
that has been
looking into UAPs.
The one thing that I think
is really significant
about this last, like, 20 years
is that if you--
Gallup did a poll in 2005.
They found that 24%
of people in the United States
believe that extraterrestrials
have visited Earth.
And when Gallup
did the same poll in 2021,
they asked people
if these UFOs--
this footage that has
been released by the Pentagon
is evidence of intelligent life
outside of Earth,
51% of people said that
they believed it was.
This staggering number
could be explained
by the desire for money
or fame.
Some people have used abduction
as a justification
for sudden absences at home,
covering for
an extramarital affair
or a particularly raucous
night out.
Psychologists have debated
in the influence
of false memories--
a scientifically
proven occurrence
where memories of incidents
that never occurred
are implanted into consciousness
with suggestive questioning
and distortion
of real-world events.
Sleep paralysis is another
proposed explanation.
Many people report
that their abductions
occurred at night
in their bedrooms
where the person
is startled awake
to find the aliens
at their bedside.
Sleep paralysis is often
accompanied by auditory
or visual hallucinations
as well as temporary
body paralysis.
Then there are comets
and asteroids to consider,
as well as
atmospheric phenomenon
like ball lightning
or St. Elmo's Fire.
Hoaxes could be
another cause.
But still, many people swear
that real contact between
humans and extraterrestrials
has occurred.
This might sound silly,
but I like to say
that the level that you believe
is also a spectrum.
You know, we talk about
gender and sexuality
being a spectrum,
but there is a huge spectrum
of people
who believe things--
the aliens are already here;
they are reptilians;
they have all these
different depictions.
And that goes to just like,
okay, UFOs have been here before
and those are extraterrestrials.
No indisputable evidence
has ever been produced
from an alien abduction--
no objects,
hybrid offspring,
devices,
or even photographic evidence.
But that doesn't mean
people have stopped believing
in extraterrestrial life.
Quite the opposite.
Then that goes to,
"These are UFOs.
Maybe they're
extraterrestrials?"
And it goes to skeptics
that are like,
"No, this is all a sham,"
or "This is all just
the government" or whatever.
So there's this big spectrum
of people
that are in this community
that all believe
different things.
And it creates
a lot of division,
a lot of drama.
People get really,
really emotional
about where they stand
and where other people stand.
We've seen more varied
interpretations
of extraterrestrial life
in the 21st century.
As our knowledge grows,
we've expanded the concept
of extraterrestrial life
past green Martians
and Grays
to sentient beings
that come to Earth
to share their knowledge.
As science and technology
advances
and our understanding
of the universe expands,
our conception of what
constitutes life does as well.
Science fiction helps us
imagine the philosophical,
practical,
and moral implications
of real encounters
between aliens and humans--
an intellectual testing ground
cloaked in the trappings
of fantasy to make it
more digestible.
And in exploring
these hypothetical scenarios,
we question what it means
to be human.
In other words,
how we conceptualize aliens
in science fiction
is often more about us
than it is about them.
I keep saying
"Euro-peein'."
(speaker)
European, yep.
[sighs]
Cool!
Rolling.
"Monstrum" intro.